[Music]
all right you can kind of see us in here
we figured we'd do them from the car cuz
it's late at night we saw a bunch of
movies today and so we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna knock out three of
them real quick here first of all I need
to talk about as we need to talk about
that Marvel movie yeah a lot of people
asked why did we do it last week it was
because it opens in a night and it was
awful
yeah so a lot of shows this week were
full also but went like midday like on
Wednesday it wasn't avengers endgame oh
you know like I said I'm not a big
Marvel guy you know but we wouldn't
watch the first Avengers at home so we
watched infinity watch infinity that way
we kind of knew about the Infinity
stones and you know blah blah blah blah
other than that were basically familiar
with all the characters anyway because
we grew up with this [ __ ] kinda bad
before it was movies just comic books
and stuff anyway yeah affinity Wars as
the [ __ ] excellent movies got a real
good soundtrack a tight script it rolls
for [ __ ] three hours it's got
fantastic effects it's everything that
Marvel fans want it it's gonna make all
the [ __ ] money in the world if you're
into this [ __ ] you need to be [ __ ]
live seeing somebody else's reviews
who's totally into this [ __ ] cuz we're
just passerby is really - it is an
excellent movie probably in all all
respects audience [ __ ] loved it
me it's okay you know it's not really my
thing I like Shazam better the reason
why there's just so many characters so
much [ __ ] happening at once to me it
kind of got tiresome three hours of it
and I just don't really care that much
about Marvel but I understand why people
do I'm not gonna hate on it it's just
I'm just kind of indifferent yeah
I actually enjoyed the movie I'm not
like a huge Marvel fan either like I
said we saw infinity war I've seen some
of the other ones like I thought if I
saw the first Thor I saw the first
ant-man I saw the first couple Iron
Man's so it's like even though I haven't
seen
you know some of the ensemble ones you
know I still know enough about the
characters and enough about what's going
on that I could still enjoy it
I actually liked this one better than
infinity war it actually had a lot more
character development type thing going
on it wasn't just like you know like a
big spectacle the whole time
and I actually thought they did a really
good I'm not gonna spoil anything you
know like because I know people are
getting upset about that
but um you know I think they did a good
job like getting me to care about the
characters and you know what ultimately
in happening to them I did think it was
slightly long but you know there was a
lot of ground to cover you know and I
kind of get that and I thought it was
like a really nice send-off for this
phase 3 like I said it's you know it's
not my genre usually um but I liked it I
thought it was pretty fun there was a
lot of humor in it which I appreciated
and you know I think they wrapped it up
pretty nicely so you know yeah if you
like Marvel you'll like it yeah I feel
like everybody's like yeah it's super
into it and I can totally me the reason
why I don't like it is just I'm just not
really I'm just not into it yeah I mean
it's just not my job yeah when you like
this exam review when you like superhero
movies you like them when they're like
kind of goofy yeah yeah I just don't I
just can't take that topic seriously and
when you try to deliver that you try to
make me believe in that universe I'm
just like meh get the [ __ ] outta here
talking I just can't see ya talkin
raccoons from other planets and targets
really doesn't just knock it the [ __ ]
off anyway uh okay
on to the next one next one was what was
naming that movie a long shot long shot
long shot Seth Rogen and Charlize Theron
yeah what do you think Jane um it was
actually pretty good
it was more of a romantic comedy than I
was expecting I was spectin it to be
more I mean it was a comedy obviously it
had like a lot of comedic moments to it
but there was actually like it was
largely a kind of unlikely love story I
actually liked it it like you said I
think it was slightly too long a little
bit of the wooden mats could have been
toned down a little bit but it had like
some cute moments and it had some funny
moments and it wasn't fantastic it
wasn't hilarious but it was enjoyable
enough I mean I like Seth Rogen he's a
likable guy and it's like you know I've
seen some of his other movies I think
this one was better than what the hell
was the North Korea yeah I don't know
that still remember I don't know who
Seth Rogen is I don't really care to
know who Seth Rogen is this is the only
second movie I've seen by a solid North
Korean one
I thought the North Korean was okay this
one I couldn't stand this one it was
like a pulling teeth
it's terrible everything I hate in a
movie that's what this was just
everything it would imagine imagine if
Woody Allen was a fat millennial that
was poorly dressed and he just pitiful
example of a man just every [ __ ]
stereotype that you could ever imagine
this movie just [ __ ] just mean the
whole thing
cramsey [ __ ] cringy pitiful Charlize
Theron actually she kind of saves
certain scenes of the movie because she
there's a couple of the Seas that she
did I I could watch that I didn't hate
those parts but I just because it was
like it was a very unbelievable story oh
man he's kind of like I said he's kind
of known for doing that's everything
like yeah it's tough and you know these
just these crazy situations so the fact
that she was in it I think kind of made
it more believable what
what stands out in this movie this movie
really achieved for me is that this
movie was actually worse than Holmes and
Watson Holmes of Watson was funnier than
this it just wasn't funny I wouldn't not
for me I didn't how's the Watson parts
of it were funny not even part this [ __ ]
is just it's just if you like cringe
then go see it if you don't want to
[ __ ] deal with cringe then I don't
want to talk about this [ __ ] okay next
one
this next one that we saw was called the
intruder and I'll tell you what with
Dennis grave this was this was a gem
this is what this is one of the this is
definitely the best one of the week and
I got a feeling that this was gonna be
one of the best ones of the month I just
liked this movie yeah I liked this
[ __ ] movie there's a low budget movie
with just basically four characters
really in it you can count five little
boys girl girlfriend of the friend
anyway it's just a simple [ __ ]
premise and it's done right it kind of
reminded me of Cape Fear in a certain
way I was thinking like and also one but
the guy that was ahead all the roaches
in the house again oh yeah yeah I was
like this reminded me very much of like
your late 80s early night
yeah and also thrillers that are made
for like Lifetime channel and something
has very much that not and I'm not
saying that like in an insulting way but
it has that kind of fatal attraction
kind of shake Heights Pacific Heights I
was thinking a white female again that
kind of vibe to it and I and I'm sure it
was intentional it seemed raw was
intentional because a lot of the humor
and it was kind of a little bit yeah
self-referential like they knew that
that's what they were doing
yeah I have to say Dennis Quaid I
displayed he'd knocked it out of the
[ __ ] Park it's like he doesn't
usually like he's he's pretty over the
top and this I think Renee really works
okay here's it usually plays good guys
and yeah it was kind of cool to have him
playing against type here's the setup
there's this young couple they're from
San Francisco alright the dude is
[ __ ] wealthy he works out of
advertising firm and he's kind of like a
genius advertiser so and the couple is
that their base they're a good-looking
mixed couple you know I mean they're
they're they're you know what
light-skinned pretty [ __ ] you
know he's got blue eyes and she's
sucking gorgeous and they [ __ ] you
know they're like a power couple alright
and they play on this later on but this
whole movie is designed to scare the
[ __ ] out of black people and if you're
black see this [ __ ] movie if you're
white go see this movie with a black
audience because we have black people in
the audience it is they were [ __ ]
getting into
they were [ __ ] remember that [ __ ]
some of the [ __ ] was going and there's
all this weird symbolism about that
Lions eating zebras and [ __ ] man this
[ __ ] was bad as what I was talking
about yeah it was very like obviously
what was going on so anyway this this
this light-skinned couple by this
[ __ ] beautiful mansion out in the
country in Napa Valley from this just
this old white dude y'all friend the old
way did well real quick you find out
this [ __ ] a monster and he
wanted he won't leave I'm just saying
like from a female perspective she
thought he was nice but she she thought
it was nice sitting there saying yeah
she thought is nice and her she asked
her girlfriend what about him and she
thought he was kind of hot she says are
young they are your guys they don't have
that that element that our dads at are
Grande no he was a woodsman okay he was
a woodsman and [ __ ] he had some
skills but anyway this [ __ ] was [ __ ]
what it did was what I liked about it is
that it did not follow normal movie
tropes yeah okay old dude was [ __ ]
swole and he was a [ __ ] badass all
right you just got to see the movie I
think you can't can't spoil these
actually it's funny because for
essentially a thriller it was actually a
lot of fun yeah like fun in that sort of
like I said I know this is gonna sound
negative because I'm gonna say cheesy
but I don't mean it in a negative maybe
was like a fun nineties thriller with
like kind of like it was very self-aware
yeah one of the things that it did is it
was written to [ __ ] play on the fears
of black people
and you could hear him back there and
they're gonna oh yes you just got a
[ __ ] seat and and it was cool it was
cool yeah and there's no real gore in it
13:13 but it's it's just got a good
thriller aspect of just creepy old white
dude won't we won't [ __ ] leave and he
does [ __ ] weird [ __ ] and he likes
your whites near he likes your
light-skinned white and he's gonna take
all your [ __ ] it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
bizarre bizarre like Quaid knocked it
out of the park he was just this [ __ ]
creep he makes a very and he was swollen
this to use that [ __ ] like wrinkly yeah
we were [ __ ] laughing surprisingly it
was I thought it was really expected
yeah yeah it was kind of a moral to the
story too it's a very very handy I had a
strong ending but that's I like him like
that said what he had to say in it okay
[Music]